نفذ ايرانيون اضرابا عن العمل في عده مدن
بينها العاصمه طهران وذلك احياء لذكرى
احتجاجاتها عامين
2019 و 2020
ونشرت مواقع عالميه الايرانيه صورا تظهر
محاله تجاريه مغلقه في العاصمه طهران ومدن
اخرى
وتظاهر اصحابه محل تجاريه في سوقين
بالعاصمه الايرانيه ورفعوا شعارات مناوعه
للنظام
قال الرئيس الايراني رئيسي ان الاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها بلاده هي واحده من مؤامرات
كثيره واكد ان طيران لن تسمح لما وصفهم
بالاعداء بالسيطره على مصير ومستقبليره
منذ بدايه الثوره الاسلاميه
الاخيره واحده من هذه المؤامرات والتاكيد
هو على ضروره تعزيز المعرفه لدى الراي
العام وجيل الشباب فاذا وجدت المعرفه لا
يمكن للعدو ان يفرض سيطرته على المجتمع لن
نسمعه للعدو بان يسيطر على مصيرنا
ومستقبلنا كما كان يفعل قبل الثوره
الاسلاميه